okay welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for a session
on algorithmic game theory
um we have an excellent batch of papers
all about designing mechanisms signaling
schemes
understanding information and data uh
a bunch of really cool papers that uh
are exploring topics that
we haven't heard a lot about before and
hopefully you're now refreshed after
learning about all different sorts of
students that we have in our community
to learn about mechanisms and
information
so we will start with gregory
so hi everyone my name is ricoch
vellegas
and today i will present you a new model
of selling information
this is going to work with my advisor
yang zhai
so as we know we live in a world that's
becoming increasingly more complex
fortunately for us there are a lot of
data out there that can help us make
more informed decisions
so the problem is that these data are
not are not immediately available to the
agents who need them
so there have been created markets that
sell information
for example consider a bank that has to
decide
whether it will approve a customer's
loan application or not
now the bank might be willing to consult
a credit reporting agency such as
equifax in order to get more information
about the client
other examples include navigation under
traffic
now in this scenario drivers are willing
to use extra information about the
current status and
waze is an application that provides
such service
the main topic of this talk will be the
seller's problem of finding the revenue
optimal way
to reveal information now in order to
analyze our problem mathematically
we adopt a model that was recently
introduced by berkmantal
in this model the uncertainty is
captured by
a set of states of the world the buyer
has to take an action
and based on the actions it takes and
the underlying state she receives a
payoff
now the knowledge that the buyer has is
captured by prior distribution over the
states
we call this prior distribution here
type
the buyer can choose to get some extra
information from the seller
and pay some price for it as in the
auction setting
we assume that the type is drawn
according to some distribution
now the way that the seller reveals
information is by sending signals that
are correlated with the underlying state
of the world
you can think of the signaling schemes
that the seller uses as tests
now based on the results of the test the
buyer might either choose to deviate a
different
action from the ones he was thinking of
taking or stick to the same one
we call the signaling schemes
experiments
in order to come up with the optimal way
to reveal information
we first have to consider how the agents
evaluate the extra information
that they get now suppose that someone
has concerns about being exposed to
covet 19
and is given the option to take a test
in this setting
there are two states of the world either
our agent is sick
or she is healthy and the actions that
she can take
are either to quarantine or go out
based on the symptoms that she is
experiencing she has figured out the
probability of her being sick
we denote this probability by theta and
this is your prior knowledge
now the results of the test are
correlated with your current state but
they're not 100
accurate you can think of the first
signal
as meaning that the result of the test
was positive and the second
signal to the test was negative now
assume that the test has a thirty
percent false negativity and thirty
percent false
positivity rate as in our case once the
agent receives a signal
she performs a bayesian update and forms
a posterior distribution
we can see here the posterior
distributions that the agent forms
after she receives one of the two
signals the red line represents her
posterior probability of her being sick
after she receives signal 1 ask a
function of your prior
and similarly for the blue line and
signal 2.
now based on the distribution that she
has formed she picks the best action for
here
in our example we see that when she
doesn't receive any information and
theta is greater than 0.5
she will choose to stay home if she
receives the first signal
she could choose to stay home if her
types greater than 0.3
and if she receives the second signal
she will only stay
home if it is greater than 0.7
in our example it's also easy to compute
the probability that it's signal sent as
the as a function of
of your type now the value of an
experiment
is simply her expected payoff after she
receives a signal from the experiment
and she maps it to the best action for
her now what i want to emphasize
is that different types can map the same
signal to different action
okay so let's now see how the valuation
looks like
for this particular example we can see
that
even in our fairly simple setting the
valuation of the agent
isn't cleaner in here type and this is
caused by the fact that
different types can interpret the same
signal in a different way
so now returning to the general model we
assume that the seller can offer
different experiments
to different types and price them
accordingly
the timeline of the interaction between
the seller and the buyer
is the following the first step is for
the seller to commit to a collection of
experiments and prices
which we call a menu once that happens
the state of the world is realized as
well as the type
of the buyer now based on her type
the buyer selects the experiment she
prefers and pays the price for it
as in the auction setting we assumed
that we assume that our buyer is
quasi-linear
after that the seller draws a signal
from the predefined distribution and
sends it to the buyer
and in her turn the buyer performs a
bayesian update
in the way we described in our example
and picks the action that maximizes your
expected
payoff based on the posterior
distribution that has formed
the last step is for the buyer to
receive the corresponding payoff based
on the state and the action that she
took
now i want to point out the crucial
difference between selling information
and selling items
let's consider the simplest auction
setting where the seller wants to sell
an item to single buyer
now assume that the seller has fixed the
probability that she gives the item to
the buyer
then we can see that the value of the
buyer for this lottery is linear in her
private type
one thing that we can immediately
observe from the previous covenanting
example
is that even in the single dimensional
environment the value of the agent for a
fixed experiment
is not linear in hit type because of the
fact that different types interpret the
same signal in a different way
now the value is a piecewise linear
function
this thing shows that our model is more
complex and presents more challenges
when we try to derive algorithms and
characterization of the optimal menu
for example bergmannetal proved that
even when there are only two states of
the world
the seller needed to use randomization
in order to maximize revenue
now i want to quickly present the
summary of our results
in the single agent setting we assume
that the tractability of the problem
depends heavily on the way that the
input is specified
we focus on three different input models
when everything is given explicitly we
prove that the
problem can be captured by polynomial
size linear program
we then saw that in the case where the
input is provided implicitly
but we have access to best response
oracle which takes distribution
over the states and returns the best
action with respect to the distribution
we can get an additive fp test as long
as the number of states is constant
finally in the implicit model where we
don't have access to that oracle we saw
that it's np
hard to approx to get a constant factor
approximation of the optimal revenue
now the original model by bermanetal
only deals with a single buyer
there are many ways one can extend the
model to a multi-agent setting
we propose as an extension and we saw
that the problem is still tractable
when the input is provided explicitly if
you are interested to learn more
about this extension please take a look
at the longer version of this talk
thank you very much for your attention i
would be happy to take any questions you
may have
great thank you um so let's switch over
to brenton and maybe we can take one
question during the switch
so if you could stop sharing your screen
yeah yeah sure
it's uh buying data now brendan
any questions we will have a panel at
the end so you can save your questions
if you'd like
yeah yeah sure
okay so now brendan will talk about
buying data over time
uh great thanks a lot can you hear me
yes
wonderful okay so uh thank you very much
uh the last talk was about selling data
uh now i'm gonna talk about buying data
uh this is joint work with nicola
morlika and ian cash
um and the
good okay so the starting point um for
this work was thinking about the demand
for data and in particular
um the fact that we can increasingly
think of data
as an important input into like a
production pipeline okay we have tech
companies who've been investing in
infrastructure
where you basically put what data into
one end of a production system and like
products come out the other end
right you put in more data uh the
quality of your products increases
um but as the sort of the size of these
data sets grow and the costs involved
become first order
this raises some questions right what
actually is the value
of adding more data into this pipeline
right how should i think about it
should i go out and invest in getting a
hundred billion more data samples or
should i
hire another data scientist okay do i
even need to go out and get more data or
can i reuse the data that i collected
last month and save some money here
all right and how should i think about
you know allocating budget to these data
sets versus other reasons
okay and and so this all suggests some
design problems sort of underlying
the strategies around acquiring data all
right so i want to think about a
framework where
i have some specific use case case for
data right there's some specific problem
i'm trying to solve
i have some cost model where i know like
how much it costs to
get and maintain my data and some
operating constraints what should my
data purchasing strategy be
and in this talk i want to focus on the
dynamic aspect of that question
which is not just how much data should i
buy but when should i buy it
okay how should i think about staleness
okay so because i only have eight
minutes let me just
dive right into a specific instantiation
of this um let's imagine i'm doing a
very simple
um estimation problem okay i've got some
hidden state of the world
which is a real number it's evolving
over time right now i want to think of
it as evolving through like gaussian
noise right so every round i add some
gaussian noise to my previous state
and i have a decision maker who's trying
to estimate this thing and i want to
think of that
they choose an action which is every
round they can either guess at the state
of the world
in which case they suffer like a squared
loss or they can pass
and just suffer a sort of fixed
disutility for not
guessing right so the the errors here
are not unbounded
um but we know we don't know what the
state of the world is so we can need to
learn it through samples okay this is
the data part
um what i can do is i can collect some
samples um and each sample is the state
of the world plus some noise
which i'm again going to assume is
gaussian okay and the gaussian this is
going to be important here
um so the way to think about this is
more samples are better if i get more
samples i have a better understanding of
what the state of the world is
the value of my guess action is better
and to make this
interesting right to get at this the
strategy acquiring data we're gonna
assume there's a budget for getting
these samples
okay so every round i get some budget
right and i can either spend it right
away or i can put in the bank and save
it so i can get more samples later
and so now my design problem is how do i
choose
adaptively how many samples to actually
go out and get every round
subject to these budget constraints in
order to minimize say my long run
expected loss
on average over time okay and i'm hiding
the the
mathematical formulation of what i mean
by that expected loss but it's what you
would imagine right if i'm doing the
optimal decision making every round
given what i know
i want to minimize that loss on average
subject to this budget constraint
okay so the reason we started with this
gaussian case is because it has sort of
this nice
property which is that my expected loss
certainly depends on the number of
samples i'm getting every round
but for gaussians it's actually going to
be independent of those sample
realizations
all right so given some strategy for
acquiring data i can actually think of
my loss as sort of traced out over time
in this nice way
where as i get more information as i
take more samples
guessing gets better as i take fewer
samples guessing gets worse
right and so i can imagine the loss i
have so this is loss okay so higher is
worse
if i'm sort of being lackadaisical about
getting samples then sort of guessing
gets worse and eventually it comes
better for me to do the outside option
then suddenly i wake up say oh i should
get more samples i'd collect more um and
switch back to guessing again okay this
is the way to think about the outcome of
policy
and sort of our service observation is
that even in this very simple setup
it's not necessarily optimal to choose a
uniform sampling strategy
right it can actually be better to do
something sort of silly like what's
written here
where i actually alternate between
sampling aggressively and sampling not
aggressively
so what is the optimal policy um so what
we we show is that you can
get to something asymptotically optimal
by going one step
sort of more complicated than uniform
sampling right so we call these on off
strategies
and the idea here is to alternate
between
don't sample at all just sort of free
ride off of the information you gathered
before
and save up your budget for some number
of rounds and then
switch to sampling at a uniform rate
until the budget you saved up is
exhausted and alternate back and forth
right we call this on off and sort of
our first result is that
on off policies will be asymptotically
optimal
right and asymptotically here because we
might need the period to grow
large um and uh i'm not going to get
into the proof details but the
motivation here is that
you know because we have these different
uses of data we can either pass or guess
um this introduces non-monotonicities in
the marginal value for data
um so it can be this can push us towards
you know buying data in batches
um and this can be this can be something
we can exploit
in order to improve our average loss
over time
um we also consider an extension right
where instead of just having a cost per
sample
we could also have a fixed cost to
collecting any positive number of
samples in a round
right so this would be something like
there's there's some extra cost involved
in actually building up the
infrastructure to actually go and get
samples at all
um and what this does is under this sort
of policy uh
under this sort of model it's not
necessarily optimal to take a you know a
long run
of getting a certain number of samples
every round so instead we look at this
class called lazy policies
in which we are maximally free riding
off of previous information that we
gathered
okay so the only rounds in which we ever
gather samples
are rounds in which we've actually
gotten worse than the outside option and
like we wouldn't be able to do anything
with data at all anymore everything's
become too stale to be useful
and our result is approximation result
which is that under this richer model
these lazy policies achieve half of the
optimal
value now you know just a word about
what the way we're describing value here
we mean half of the extra value over the
default outside option
of just passing every round right so we
want to think of the
extra benefit over passing around it's
like the value of data
it's what we're getting beyond a world
where we got no date at all and we get
at least half of that value through
these lazy policies
um again can't say too much about the
the details let me just
tease a little bit of what's going on um
that value
we can think of as the area sort of
under
this orange curve between the orange
curve and the green curve remember
green's the outside option
will choose the orange curve when it
goes below the green so we can think of
this area down here as like the value of
our sampling policy
we come up with an upper bound of that
policy by sort of you know geometrically
sort of throwing these
these squares in here and it turns out
that we can think of these
lazy policies as some sort of sawtoothy
pattern where we're being very extreme
and just taking a ton of samples and
then free writing off of it
um and you know a triangle is half the
area of a square and so this is where
our two approximation comes through
the hard part of this is showing that if
this orange curve is feasible with
respect to the budgets then this red
curve will be feasible as well
and that turns out to be the case
okay so just concluding thoughts this
was a very specific
instantiation of this broader framework
about trying to understand
not just how much data i should buy but
when i should buy it
even in this very simple case there's
this non-monthly and marginal value of
data
which leads to interesting solutions um
where we want to collect data in bursts
uh there's i think a lot of juice left
to squeeze out of this orange right you
can think about applying this
in like a lot of different scenarios for
uses for data um
different sort of incentive constraints
or supply constraints or whatnot
um and there's so but this all sort of
falls within the scope of this broader
framework
that we started exploring all right
thank you very much
cool thanks brendan um let's switch over
to martin
and we can take a question as we switch
over
everybody wants to hold them for the
panel
okay all right then we will have
martin talk about algorithmic persuasion
with evidence also i want to do a quick
plug and just say
i've watched all of the long talks and
they're all amazing they all have
beautiful slides as i'm sure you've seen
the slides are very beautiful so
i recommend watching the long talks as
well they talk at a slightly slower pace
than they're talking in these
eight-minute talks
so go ahead martin okay can you hear me
can you hear me yes sorry yes okay cool
okay so uh this is uh on algorithmic
persuasion with evidence and it's joint
work with uh
pasan and alex okay so what we study in
this paper is an elementary game of
persuasion so there's a sender and a
receiver
and the difference is the sender has
information about the state of the world
and the receiver is the one to take an
action
so i mean naturally the sender wants to
exploit his informational advantage and
wants to influence the receiver to take
an action
in her favor and here we have an
elementary case of that so
essentially the sender just wants to
persuade the receiver to change the
status quo
so for instance the sender could be an
attorney and he wants to con convince a
judge to
convict the defendant or the senders
maybe a candidate
a job candidate and wants to convince
the company to hire her
now the receiver on the other hand has
more pronounced preferences
and she wants to make or he wants to
make a correct decision
so we assume that the state of the world
falls into one of two classes namely
acceptable or rejectable
and acceptable is essentially the status
quo should be changed so the defendant
is guilty or the candidate is good so we
should hire we should
convict and rejectable is the opposite
so here we should
reject the candidate or or not convict
the defendant
okay let's make this thing a little bit
more uh formal to see
exactly what's going on so the state of
the world is actually drawn from a
distribution d this distribution key is
both known to both send and receiver
now the sender like i said wants the
receiver to accept no matter what the
receiver on the other hand wants to make
a correct decision
so what they do is they determine a
signaling scheme
for the sender so he essentially sees
the state of the world and then sends a
signal a message
to the receiver and the receiver is an
action scheme upon hearing that message
upon hearing that signal
he determines which action to take
right so here is the the information so
the sender actually sees the realization
of the state of the world and he knows
how the receiver will react so he then
sends a signal the receiver does not
know the state of the world but he knows
the distribution and he knows well
how this signal comes into place and
then receives the signal takes an
action finally utilities well utility is
one for the sender whenever the receiver
accepts zero otherwise
utilities one for the receiver if he
does the correct decision
so it's one for acceptable state and
accept action
it's one for rejectable state reject
action and zero otherwise
now that's a very elementary game and
it's very simple to
see what's going on there and i
encourage you to do so
so what makes things interesting in this
scenario is the following variant that
has been put forward by glaze and
rubenstein in the econometric
paper in 2004 and its persuasion with
evidence and evidence means the signals
are not arbitrary
so we have to provide concrete evidence
on what's going on the state of the
world
so you have to provide concrete evidence
whether the defendant is guilty
or whether you're a good candidate and
this evidence could be like grades or
papers or things like this
so formally this model like this so you
have this this
state evidence or state signal graph
where here is the states of the world
and they are acceptable or rejectable
like green and white
there's this prior over the state of the
world and then there is this known
state signal graph which means in which
state of the world can i put forward
which evidence which collection of
evidence
so that's the input to the problem
now the sender determines the signaling
scheme could be something like this
so here it's almost deterministic in
these two states he sends this signal
in this state he sends this signal here
he actually randomizes 50 50 between
these two signals
okay now the receiver sees this and says
well i mean if i get this leftmost
signal here then well
i mean i get it 30 of the time and then
like 20
it's a rejectable state 10 is an
acceptable state so my best response
here would be to reject
right and so you can do this beijing
update for each of the signals and then
turns out these are the best response
actions of the receiver
okay good now seeing this of course the
sender says well you know i want to
maximize the probability
that the state of the world is changed
so the accept action is played so i want
to route as much probability here to
this
accept signal so i want to send this as
often as possible
so for instance so for in this case the
sender would actually
change to that and now you can sort of
play this again and see this is actually
an equilibrium
so here the sender best responds to the
action scheme of the receiver and the
receiver best response to the
signaling scheme of the center it's not
the only equilibrium here in this case
i encourage you to look at this so
there's other equilibria
but this is one of the problems we study
here uh
so compute such an equilibrium right so
can we find
an equilibrium like that right
constraint equilibrium find a sequential
equilibrium
then we also study two scenarios with
commitment power
commitment power means that you actually
have
one agent who commits to
a certain behavior and then pulls goes
through with it
and anticipates the response of the
other so it's not necessarily an
equilibrium but it's more like a buy
level optimization problem
so the sender says okay this is the way
a signal anticipating the best response
of the receiver
trying to maximize its utility same
thing could be for the receiver he says
well this is the actions i'm going to
take
i'm going to anticipate what the sender
is saying sending me in terms of
information and signals
and i'm picking this action scheme to
maximize the result
now it's heavily debated in economics
whether these commitment power
assumptions are actually realistic
and we don't want to join into this
debate uh here we just
study both of these scenarios from a
computational perspective
well if you think about the motivation
maybe if you're a big company then maybe
you have commitment power and you say
okay
these are the concrete evidence i want
to see
unless i won't hire you right so this
may be
a scenario where the commitment power is
with the receiver so that would be the
delegation case here
uh you could also maybe envision
scenarios where the commitment powers
with the sender but as i said i mean in
terms of
interpretation it's up to debate anyway
so what are the results uh so one of the
first results is the equilibrium problem
can be solved in polynomial time
so i don't want to go deeply into this
the main message
is it's a max flow based construction
based on which we can
compute full disclosure though
these equilibria can be quite bad in
comparison to the commitment power
solutions if you have commitment power
there are scenarios where
the commitment power agent can
significantly improve his utility
so we also study these commitment power
uh variants
and turns out they're actually quite
hard so there's a
trivial or a very simple o of n
approximation algorithm for the
persuasion case
there's a simple two approximation for
the delegation case
and these are essentially also hard so
we have an n to the one minus epsilon
hardness for any constant epsilon that's
max independent set hardness and we also
have a two minus epsilon hardness for
the delegation for any constant epsilon
so even though this seems to like a very
elementary game
like these persuasion and delegation
scenarios can be
very hard and actually hard up to
trivial algorithms to approximate
so that's why we thought okay what about
special structure what about more
structured instances what about things
like i have a unique acceptable state
i have a unique rejectable state every
state
has only two possible signals every
state has only the
possible signals things like this and we
went through with this
and we found different algorithms right
so there's a variety of algorithmic
techniques that we use in these these
in these scenarios maybe the most
interesting one is these degree two
states
where we have a semi-definite
programming based approximation
algorithm
who gives us a 1.1 approximation but
there's also like integer programming
rounding here
and there is a pitas here based on
enumeration so i guess the general
message is that the persuasion scenarios
are generally much
harder than the delegation scenarios
but also delegation is hard and we
actually need special structure here in
this
in this in this domain and of course
there's many open problems here
so like extend the elementary scenario
to more
general utilities or think of other
meaningful scenarios where you can do
good approximation or even polynomial
time algorithms
things like this and that's it from
myself
thank you
okay thank you martin um and let's save
questions for the panel
so our fourth speaker is a total
surprise
uh guest guest speaker uh
we'll have brendan again um and he will
be speaking about a paper sentence that
has quasi linear in the title twice
thank you uh for that uh and hello
everyone again i can hear me again now
fantastic oh there we go um yeah so
uh good this is joint work uh with moshe
pabaya richard cole
jason heartland nicole malika and so
this is a paper about
auctions and mechanisms so i'm going to
start with just a
very quick you know some background by
looking at an extremely standard
sort of auction design type of question
okay so i want to imagine i have an
allocation problem
um i have some goods an apple that a
banana i want to allocate them to some
users you know pink and purple
the users have value for the goods and
values for combinations of the goods
let's imagine those values are coming
together additively right and my goal as
a designer
is to come up with some way to partition
the goods amongst the buyers
to maximize some objective and for now
let's say it's total value
okay so completely trivial optimization
problem algorithmic game theory session
um so the issue here is strategic
behavior
very standard way to solve this is to
introduce payments
okay so we can do is we can assume that
the users say have
quasi-linear utilities which is to mean
that we can measure their values
in dollars and then assume that they
relate the value of what they get
with uh what they have to pay through a
linear function
uh like this down here um now the title
of the talk should give a hint that
we're going to revisit this
quasi-linearity here but for now let's
just go with it
okay so if we assume this
quasi-linearity then there's you know
very strong uh
solutions to this type of problem we
have select the vcg mechanism
which in this case just says give every
good to whoever bid the most on it
and they pay the second highest bid on
that item
um under this mechanism and these
payments um everyone will declare their
values truthfully we get the maximize
maximum value
okay beautiful theory very rich um
there's a lot of work in econ cs that
applies this to a bunch of different
allocation problems and algorithms
to try to understand um you know how to
get people to behave truthfully
but the thing we want to go after here
is that this relies very crucially on
this quasi-linearity assumption
and this cause of linearity is not
uncontroversial you know in economics
more broadly
okay so you know this tends to be a you
know a standard way to model people when
you have like small stakes
payments but once payments get large um
this is perhaps a little questionable
okay a more robust and general model is
to assume that people have a disutility
for payments that's not necessarily
linear
right in particular say it's convex in
the amount of money that's being spent
all right so we think about this is that
people have a value for goods in utility
and they have a disutility for payments
also measured in utility
and let me spend a minute motivating
this convexity here convexity captures
the fact that each dollar that you spend
is a little more painful a little more
costly than the last
okay and so why is that reasonable it
captures a bunch of different things
like for example
the users might have budgets they might
not have an infinite amount of money
available to spend
which means that when they spend money
on your mechanism they're taking that
money away from some other use for it
okay so the value of spending an extra
dollar here
is not a dollar it's what they would
have spent that dollar on if they
weren't spending on apples and bananas
okay and they would pick up take money
away from less valuable things first and
then more valuable things as you force
them to pay more and more
and that gives you this convexity um it
also captures things like risk aversion
and so on a lot of different
utility sort of models captured here
okay great so suppose that we you know
believe that you know
more generally agents might have these
convex disutility for payments
so now there's a robustness question
here okay so we've developed this rich
theory so
to building these like best practices
and mechanisms
you know for quasi-linear agents what
would happen if we take these things and
deploy them in these richer environments
where people might not
be quasi-linear okay have we been giving
bad advice to these tech companies who
are using this theory to sell
ads and so on um and i want to emphasize
that this is a
robustness type question okay so these
you know dis-utility curves we're
thinking of them as being completely
unknown and the mexicans agnostic to
them
right we have a mechanism designed for
quasi-linear environments
right and so i want to compare this to a
like a beautiful line of literature
we're looking at designing mechanisms
for specific utility models that are
non-linear
okay that's not what we're doing here
we're saying if i take a
mechanism that's truthful if agents are
quasi-linear and dump it in this richer
environment
what happens well what happens um so
certainly the
we lose truthfulness okay the mexicans
aren't even direct revelation anymore
okay the agents aren't expressing their
utilities to us
um but our sort of our first and main
result
is that at the equilibrium behavior
there's some nice structure that pops up
okay so for a general class of social
choice problems right much more general
than this additive case i started with
at equilibrium the agents will have best
responses
where they take their valuation
functions and scale them by uniform
factors okay so we will take their
evaluation functions
and they might not report them
truthfully but they'll scale them down
by some uniform factor
right so in particular in this additive
case in general an agent could declare
like an arbitrary bid for every good
but they always have a best response
where they take their bids for the
different goods and sort of reduce them
down
by some uniform factor and in fact the
factor is interpretable
these scalars we can think of them as
corresponding to the return on
investment
that the agents get at the equilibrium
that that results
when we run the mechanism
we can also ask about the properties of
these equilibria okay there could be
more than one
but here we give a price of anarchy
style result if we focus in on that
additive case right that i started with
and we think of running this vcg
mechanism
what we show is that every equilibrium
of this form gets us at least half
of an appropriate notion of the optimal
welfare and we have to be careful here
about how we define welfare because
we've gone outside of the realm of
quasi-utilities
and so it's not even obvious how you
should aggregate up the utilities of all
the different agents i'm going to say
more about that in a moment
okay so let me spend the rest of my time
just taking those results and staying
them a little more formally
for this equilibrium scenario what we're
saying is take any mechanism
that would be truthful if the agents
were quasi linear and take any
value functions for the agents and these
you know cost of money these like this
utility curves that are convex
then for every agent no matter how the
other agents are bidding there's always
a best response for them
in which they take their value function
and scale it by this factor
moreover there always exists a pure nash
equilibrium in which all the agents are
behaving in this way
okay some notes about this okay so this
holds for a reasonably general class of
social choice problems
really the the main condition we need is
convexity of the outcome space
which we can think of as saying it's the
mexicans able to randomize
um but you know outside tonight it's
actually quite general
um the other thing i want to point out
is that there's a lot of delicacy here
around tie breaking that i'm completely
sweeping under the carpet here like if
we say that there exists a pure nash
equilibrium let's raise some red flags
like oh you know doesn't tiebreaking
come into this and it does um and so
more formally what i'm saying is that
there is a way to sort of
define your tie breaking rules so that a
pure nash equilibrium exists
but please see the paper for more
details about that
um now for this price of anarchy result
um i want to say more about the way we
would define
welfare here so we'd like to say
something like these equilibria that we
come up with
are approximately efficient but we need
to be careful like in particular
something that we can do
is we could take one buyer and blow up
their utilities for outcomes by a factor
of a million
and also blow up their disk utility for
payments by a factor of a million
that would not affect their strategic
behavior at all they'd be completely
equivalent from a mexican's perspective
but their utilities are clearly out of
scale so it's difficult to sort of
aggregate these up
and so what we do is we define what we
call transferable welfare
which sort of leans into this idea that
we should define welfare in this common
uh units which we call money right so
we'll say that the agent's willingness
to pay for an outcome
is how much they'd be willing to pay to
get that outcome as opposed to getting
nothing
okay so we can read this off of this
curve here like for a given outcome
we can draw you know here's the value
you'd get in utility
and look at the intersection with the
curve this is how much to be willing to
pay
and then transferable welfare is the sum
of this value over all the different
ages so you can think of this as how
much would the pool of agents be willing
to pay in aggregate
in order for this mechanism like to fund
this mechanism like how much would they
be willing to pay
and i want to note this generalizes the
standard notion of welfare for
quasi-linear agents
it also generalizes the notion of liquid
welfare for budgeted agents
right which is the minimum of the value
and the budget
and so it's taking those those notions
and extending them to these general
curves
good and so under that notion of welfare
we get this price of anarchy result
um at any equilibrium of this form um
for these mechanisms we get half of the
optimal
transferable welfare and that's i want
to clarify this
specifically for this additive case okay
so to summarize
mechanisms for quasi-linear agents dump
them in this environment where agents
are not necessarily quasi-linear
um what happens we get this type of
equilibrium where agents just scale by
these
constant factors there are some notions
in which their outcomes are
approximately efficient
future directions um you know extending
the the analysis to more general classes
but also things like
these are all existence results we'd
like to understand things about
computation as well
great thanks very much
cool thank you um and thank you to all
the speakers this is a great session
um so now we are going to go into the
panel part
i have prepared a bunch of questions but
i'm also happy to take questions from
anyone and also as we move into the
panel i'm happy to have any of the
authors
discussed so i think you're all already
panelists if you're here if any of you
are
attendees and you want to raise your
hand so you can be promoted that's fine
too
um cool so if you have a question you
want to ask the authors feel free we can
also
if anybody has individual questions
there's a virtual coffee break on gather
at 12 30 hopefully some of the authors
will be around to chat one-on-one
uh so if nobody has a question right now
then i will start off with my questions
okay great um so a lot of
i think all of these papers really
surround
uncertainty like much of mechanism
design and so
i guess the question is what what's the
crux of uncertainty and the problems
that you're working on
how is it defining your problem making
it more challenging or making the
outcomes better in some cases
what do you think the the crux of
uncertainty in your problem is
anyway
uh sure okay let me take a crack at that
for the
talk i just gave the one about non-quasi
linearity and i think they're the
really the uncertainty here is around
you can think of as like
the broader context outside of the
mechanism that we're designing
like part of the idea is that you know
the way that the agents are going to
respond
depends a lot on you know what options
are available for them
for money sort of outside of this space
and so somehow there's this sense in
which
um there might be uncertainty there's
just inherent like we
it can't we can't expect to be able to
actually extract all of that information
from the users in some reasonable
mechanism and so somehow we need to
come up with the right set of knobs to
expose to actually get people to behave
in a reasonable way
and sort of like have this you know user
in the loop almost sort of scenario
where the users
won't be able to tell us information
directly but somehow interact with what
we expose to them
can i um comment on that too i think um
a crucial thing with this uncertainty uh
that you mentioned
is and especially with regard to
mechanism design where the
prominent approach is to look at
truthful mechanisms
and in truthful mechanisms all of the
uncertainty that comes from the agents
knowing stuff has to be reported to the
designer
in a direct report direct revelation
truthful mechanism
and that just doesn't
seem to be a great sort of
balance between like you know where the
sort of hard work is happening and you
know what this
this paper that brendan just presented
is trying to get around says that
actually you know simple mechanisms
that don't try to you know have a
message space it's as complicated
as the agent's actual uh you know
valuation space um actually
you know have good equilibria and then
you let the agents do a little bit of a
calculation
it turns out it's a single dimensional
calculation for all them how much like
what's the multiple factor to shade
and that's actually still pretty easy
compared to like it's
it's not it's not like a high
dimensional optimization they have to do
a high dimensional
you know non-convex operation that would
have to do it's actually to find this
equilibrium
it's a single dimensional optimization
for each agent um
which seems like it's you know well
within the
realm of reasonable and
you know i just think that this is
where we're gonna be with real
mechanisms
always we're never going to be having
we're always going to be sort of in a
mis-specified model
where you know there's additional stuff
in the agent's cost function that we
haven't modeled in our mechanism design
so the mecca is never going to be
truthful and
the question is is do these truthful
mechanisms you know are they robust they
degrade nicely
with this we're not and um and i think
that getting at your question cara i
think this is just a phenomenal
you know area and i think that you know
we have to embrace this area and we
haven't really done
such a good job of that yet um
and uh you know actually
um there's a
cool connection here to distributed
systems that i like a lot which is sort
of the end-to-end principle that says
or and there's also like this idea of
like you know do the computation where
the data is
right which says that if someone's got
complicated you know constraints
they should do the complica the
computation around optimizing their
constraints for something not they
shouldn't just like ship all their
constraints
some central planner to do it um that's
going to create
you know very complicated not robust
mechanisms versus
the sort of you know let people sort of
optimize themselves so i think that this
is sort of a
super important direction for us and i
just like
you know we have to work in this area
and we haven't done enough of it
i could discuss that for a long time but
i want to give the other
authors a chance to talk about their
papers
so the question was about uncertainty in
your paper
yeah i see that rad has a hand up i just
wanted to let the other authors respond
before we move to the next question
if they want to we don't have to
okay uh rad did you want to ask your
question yeah sure uh
so i think that's the question for
brandon about the last talk
the first half of the last stock uh so
how do you
define welfare in that problem is it
just gonna be some of the utilities of
the buyers plus
some of the payments
sorry in the so for the the transferable
welfare
definition uh yes so
basically if i want to think about the
welfare
when you have these additive uh additive
utilities but
the convex functions are changing the
payments um
so what's the what's the welfare is it
just like the sum of the
values or is it the sum of the values
minus
the sum of the convex functions at the
payments plus the sum of the payments
yeah okay so they're good so there are a
bunch of there are many reasonable ways
you could imagine defining it um
the way that we take is this
transferable welfare notion so we
basically
say we want to define the value being
generated basically in dollars
so we literally just say for every agent
how much would you be willing to pay
for your outcome and we actually define
that this is the no
this is the quantity that we're trying
to maximize and so we say we get a half
approximation like that's the quantity
we get
now for the second right also in the
first half you i guess you didn't care
about welfare you just want no so this
was this was just
so that was just saying like what is the
nature like what are the equilibria look
like
but in general we weren't trying to you
know argue about the welfare properties
now you could apply you could ask the
same question sort of more generally and
i think there are open questions there
that are really interesting
and and then one other clarifying
question so uh
i can still implement externality
payments after applying the inverse of
the
convex function right so there is
another true
so rather than the non-truthful
mechanism that you
analyze that equilibrium there is also a
truthful mechanism here
because we essentially have a
quasi-linear agent in disguise
right so i can just like find the
externality payments and
apply the inverse of the convex function
or
absolutely so good so if you knew what
those curves were
then you could generate payments that
would cause things to be truthful
absolutely and i think that there there
are you know for for any
particular you know way like classes of
these curves
you could set up what those payments
would be and there's like a lot of work
that sort of goes into like this class
for that
versus that class and so i'd say that's
sort of an orthogonal direction so what
we're looking for here is if we don't
know the curves at all so we can't
implement that solution
what happens as a result of not being
able to do through full payments and
i need that sorry why is that true
brendan it's not quasi-linear
no i mean it didn't feel additive json
so you can just
do a change
you'd have to have a linear payment to
add to that which is not in the payments
function and how do you do that
i calculate the accident payments using
the values
they're inseparable you separable i just
then i just use let's call it p-i-teal
to be
c-i-f-p-i so p-i-c you're going to
invert the payment function to make
someone's pain be
what it should be in the quantity yes
yeah exactly
um i think there's a question in the
chat for brennan from
simo and then grant has the question
after that
so the question from simon is uh about
the khan
the convexity assumption on the
disutility
and is there a world where it could be
concave
how crucial is the convex city
assumption
i would say the convexity assumption is
crucial to the results
um now whether there are other
environments that go beyond convexity
sure i mean absolutely and you might
imagine that you know but
um yeah so for example like if someone
is
like risk loving or something like this
you could imagine some sort of model
um i would say that that's less standard
than the convex model but
i think exploring environments where
like what would go on with certain
ways of going beyond convexity would be
a reasonable thing to think about
uh grant
a question that just a prompt for
discussion
so i would say there's some papers here
about buying and selling of debt even
the uncertainty
there seems a huge between uh
theory and practice buying and selling
of data
um and uh so the question is and
you know maybe jason provided a a good
answer
to this but i'm sure there are more um
what are the
issues that are kind of dividing either
what are the issues that are dividing
the theory from the press
and how could we make our theory um
a little closer what are the deep
philosophical questions that our theory
is trying to answer
if it's just there there's value apart
from practice but then
in that case what are the big questions
that we're trying to answer
i mean okay so maybe a little bit of a
pity answer but like the so one
certainly division between the theory
and the practice here is that a lot of
the theory is sort of saying
you know let's look ahead to a model to
a world where there is like a robust
market and then try to think about now
like how would i think about it
but you know in practice there are a lot
of frictions in order to actually
building a market like that and having
it be
robust um and i think one of those
frictions is the fact that
you know the value of data is quite
context dependent right so like how
valuable is
you know a bunch of samples from some
data source
well it's difficult perhaps to sort of
argue about that
in a very general sort of sense um since
different
it's really going to depend on the
particular usage and so i think that
one thing that i feel like a lot of the
literature sort of you know start
starting to go in on is really focus on
particular
ways of using data to sort of try to at
least
get a starting point like get a foothold
on you know i can't really talk about
the value of data but maybe i can talk
about the value of samples
to a data analyst who's doing regression
um and having one one barrier to
practical systems is to be able to have
some kind of marketplace
where perhaps people with a lot of
different use cases and minds can all
sort of interact
simultaneously with the same same thing
where evaluations are very different
um and so i think that's been sort of a
difficult thing
for practitioners in theory folks to
sort of simultaneously get their hands
on
so i just want to supply jason's answer
i think you do like
jason's answer is one one thing is that
we the
theory has been focusing on these
revelation mechanisms and
in reality we want robust simple
mechanisms and that that would probably
uh work a lot better
there's an other thoughts out there
because i i mean i i love this area and
i love the papers here and i've written
papers on it
but i i wonder how to get from where we
are to where we
want to go
i think the um the simple versus optimal
paradigm is going to be super valuable
here
uh and the reason why is that
you know if you try to do statistics
the optimal like experiment to run if
you've got a complicated statistical
question
like you know getting like nice
understanding of that object that comes
back is like
really like you know our theory can't do
it
um and you know maybe you could do it
algorithmically
uh but i'm not sure what that would look
like
and so um i think that that's a big sort
of
blocker here uh you know i
with shikichala and dennis i had a
a couple papers in ec 14 and 16 about
trying to like design mechanisms to get
good data
right and it was just like super hard to
sort of characterize what good
mechanisms look like because
the statistics is so messy so you're not
going to get something that says
this is optimal because statistics is
messy and so how do you deal with the
fact that
the statistical value is you know
fundamentally like you want to minimize
your error right
with respect to something and so you
know those bounds are so
loose typically that what do you do
yeah i mean so just just an anecdote
building on that so like
many some i don't know eight nine years
ago at some point i i was speaking with
some people inside microsoft from the
sigma community like the database
community
and they were really struggling with
this question of like how should i price
database queries
right so i have a user who wants to make
a query against the database
like how should i price it and they want
to say things like well if it's
data that they'd already gotten
previously maybe they should pay less or
something like this and actually trying
to get at the information value of
different queries
and it was just a a bunch of people had
sort of taken shots at this and then
completely given up and so somehow
like yeah so just to echo jason's point
i think that like actually trying to get
at
like valuing these things you know
ourselves as sort of
the seller is maybe like less promising
than saying like
i'm gonna have some class of like
pricing schemes or something like this
and then let sort of the demand side of
the market
work out how valuable things are from
them and then hope that something like
you know market equilibrium pricing or
something like somehow takes over and
drives and that like
there's some simple class of things
where we can learn from people's
behavior what should be more expensive
than what
um without having to like centralize
like in a central way like derive
everything ourselves which just feels
like a non-starter
yeah i guess one thing about that
solution that always um like i i'm not
entirely sure
how where i fall along these lines is in
some sense we
are pushing the complexity onto the
agents in the setting as opposed to
absorbing them as the mechanism designer
and
so i think that's great but i think it
should come along with
a different model of behavior i think
we're a bit too tied to irrationality
assumptions but like bayesian
rationality assumptions
especially if we want to start pushing
other
um complexities into the agent's uh
like you know domain and we would be
well
uh served by looking into the behavioral
economics literature and trying to
leverage some of those models
is it to brandon's point
like maybe we're currently already doing
some of this
which is a few people value the data a
lot namely advertisers
and they extract it and collect it and
keep it to themselves and use it and
it's basically not available to anyone
else who has less value for it
like social science researchers or
things like that
can i sort of follow up on what nicole
said and ask
a question which is um do
do researchers overall think that like
hyper rationality assumptions are
fairly practical like when you're
selling an advertisement
are you selling that to a person is a
person gonna click
or like is the company gonna have some
algorithms that they've fine-tuned and
their data scientists are like pretty
sure this is their exact value
for things um like
one of those sides does seem like
behavioral economics is
going to be a crucial thing and the
other one
i've always had in my head as like the
fit for quasi-linear
utilities um which of our
many researchers who have worked or work
in industries
like to
i'm not sure if we have brendan i'm
sorry quasi
behavioral versus quasi-linear are two
orthogonal questions
uh so i'm not sure you you ended with
quasi-linear but you started with
behavioral so i'm not sure what the [ __ ]
thank you
sorry asian rationality with
priors and updating and stuff
my favorite example here is the dutch
flower auctions and the point is is that
these
auction buyers go in every single day
and they're people not algorithms
but if they were bad they would get
fired so
they better be rational so i don't think
it's albums versus people i think it's
repeated versus not repeated
um that's a big difference uh and a lot
of the behavioral
game theory looks at first round
behavior for exactly this reason
because it's just quite a different
beast uh to look at first round behavior
from
repeated behavior um and by the way i
love
the recent work uh that our community is
doing
on repeated behavior and like using
regret
as the bound instead of the notion
instead of truthfulness like i i did
that that's amazing work
like this is really um huge contribution
yeah i guess along those lines like from
the industry perspective we do a lot of
um like these bidding automated bidding
agents are
often doing things like learning doing
no regret learning style algorithms in
the background
so trying to fit them to
worlds in which there's priors and
there's updating and they're playing
some repeated game and they
you want to find a pbe like i think is
pretty unrealistic
and also in terms of the
behavioral being appropriate for games
we play once like one of
application where i like to think about
behavioral agents is
uh school choice markets for example so
i do a bunch of work in the matching
literature
and there i imagine parents are not
really playing a repeated game
are they rational or very unrational
almost like because it is high stakes so
maybe well i'm not a parent but
i've worked with this on brendan and i
think he has opinions
i mean i i think that like this is a
place where like the repeated version
but also like things like evolutionary
stability and things sort of make sense
like i i wouldn't necessarily say that a
certain solution concept is
predictive because it's an equilibrium
when everyone's hyper rational
but you know if i have a solution where
there's some
deviation that people could make to sort
of improve their
their outcomes then i would say that
that
that place that we're starting from is
probably not predictive at least in the
long run
right we sort of expect that if there's
some deviation that people could make
and benefit from it eventually they'll
figure it out right and someone will
make a blog post and then suddenly
everyone will just like switch doing
this other thing even if they don't
completely understand why
right so you know yeah when we were
thinking about like parents
and and playing these mechanisms for
like school choice and such it was it
was amazing how
important like the playground
conversations were to like what people
actually did
right so there's a lot of just people
discussing with each other without even
fully understanding
like oh you should just you know you
should do this thing and then you'll end
up with a better outcome
like this but i think it's very hard let
me let me
let me interject for a second and just
say that the other session is going to
be starting in room a
uh on algorithms chaired by sam hawkins
you're welcome
to go to the other session uh because we
have two rooms we can stay here and
continue this awesome
discussion as long as we want i will be
staying here
so if you want to go to the other
session feel free if you need to drop
off feel free
and we can continue now
i was just saying like in school choices
and like continuing that example it's
very hard
to convince people to list their
uh true preference ordering even if
you're running deferred acceptance like
parents think oh this school is hard to
get into
so i should shouldn't like risk my
second
choice uh even though it's not like you
know it
it's hard to prove that right and i
guess that's maybe what
shang wu is trying to talk about an
obvious strategy-proofness
and so we need to think about other
mechanisms in that world is my opinion
yeah and i think of venatan has all
those papers about
as well with experiments
there's a there's a big dichotomy in uh
like mechanism design versus to say
market design
and one of the big differences is market
design is typically focusing on
the one-shot games where things like
obviously strategy proofness and
truthfulness are super important because
of this
potential behavioral element whereas
much of the mechanism design literature
uh
you know that would have a basin prior
for example
um is much more relevant in the repeated
scenario where
actually the rationalities or at least
you know
no regret for repeated whatever is is
you know a reasonable assumption and so
and
if you look across these two literatures
the methods and techniques are just
entirely different and for good reason
the point is is that like there's one
thing that you wanted is one way to
design things for single round and you
either need to be behavioral or you need
to be obviously strategy proof or
something
and there's another way to design things
for repeated interactions which does not
need that
and is you know most of what we call
mechanism design
yeah i had other questions prepared i
don't know if you want me to throw them
out there but
yeah um well so for instance a lot of
these papers actually had a lot to do
with like temporal aspects and repeated
actions
and for example is martin's still here
yeah martin's still here
um like like his paper had a lot to do
about whether
you were able to commit or not uh
brendan
at all's uh the first paper that brendan
talked about had to do
was that the first yeah um had to do
about you know
this problem of buying data over time
and whether it's still or not
um grigoris's paper
uh i know is like in the single shot
case and it's a completely different
problem
if you allow there to be multiple
interactions
in the single shot case you are able to
sort of import all of these
solutions that we know from for example
revenue maximization
and in the multi-round case this is a
problem that i think
moshe and bobby and someone else
have studied yeah okay um so you know
like the
the temporal aspect like really changes
the scenario here
so speaking of repeated interactions i
just i don't know if you
wanted to comment on that at all
like another theme in the session
especially the commitment aspect
yeah so this this did pop up with the
puppy with bobby and renato
and the issue of commitment and whether
you can
escape in the middle of the mechanism or
you have to stay till the end
yeah and martin you you look at
when you commit the commitment players
utility increases but it never
you can never increase the other
player's utility by having commitment
power is that correct
or did you not look at that question i'm
not sure i mean there might be cases
where it depends on what they i mean the
equilibrium is not unique right you
might come up with examples where
there's bad equilibria which are
bad for both of them so i mean it's not
as i mean i know your bounds are for the
for the commitment player but yeah
but it's not a zero-sum game right so
they might both profit
by not getting stuck in a bet
that's interesting and in the in the
selling information game the revenue
increases
when you when you don't have to commit
or
so in the selling information game i
think that when there is
interaction you can extract the whole
welfare
i think that this in our case it's not
supposed to be to extract the whole uh
welfare
i see see
well back to you know
interesting okay i mean i guess just a
a maybe a high-level meta point on this
on on that on that theme
is that i think that um
you know in our community like these
sort of dynamic multi-round
games sometimes have a bit of a bad rap
for
you know solution concepts get very
carry and it's really difficult to study
and oftentimes you know we're there's
there's a
tendency to say okay we're gonna take
the models that people are studying in
the static setting right now and move
into a dynamic setting and see what
happens and those
those static models are complicated
already um
but i mean i i think some of this work
you know like even extremely simple like
looks like almost trivial models in like
a static case actually becomes very
interesting both technically and
economically
when you have multiple rounds and
you know as jason was pointing out
earlier we have these concepts from
computer sciences like
other solution concepts that aren't
super hyper rational that actually let
us dig into what's happening in some of
these
um multi-round dynamic settings you know
like real great minimization and what
have you
um and so i think there's like a rich
ground now to sort of like take your
favorite
problem space take a very simple version
of it
look at a multi-round instance and bikes
just see what pops out
and so i think there's low hanging fruit
in a lot of places here
i'm gonna ask one more question uh and
then we can and if nobody else has any
others uh
for sort of a fun question and this is
not the fun question i was planning on
asking but i called you brethren
um so these are all like you know very
economy problems
and so i guess why did you pick
this aspect of econ to work on and then
what's your favorite cse component of it
so a two-parter
why this aspect of econ for your problem
and then
within the work what's your favorite csc
component
that makes it you know any itcs
so all of you have to answer
it's mandatory you cannot leave the zoom
call unless you answer
i mean okay so i think in
trending i think there's a comment
there's a comment yeah okay so i'm i'm
gonna answer i guess i have four
questions to answer but it's gonna be
sort of a common
common answer which is that i think that
um
you know there's this there's this
wonderful thing that computer science
can bring to some of these economy
questions which is like this
you know this notion of like looking at
approximation right so like
um i think that in a lot of cases
we have these environments where we we
add just enough
twists that actually characterizing
what's
what's like what's the optimal solution
like what what's you know what's the
information theoretically
or you know mechanism design-ish sort of
optimal thing
goes outside the realm of
being sort of reasonable or practical or
nice to specify
um and i think that one thing that's
really exciting for us as a community
people to do is just sort of like take
one step
beyond that threshold and then be able
to say things there because we bring in
this toolkit of like
you know we can't specify the optimal
thing but we can talk about robustness
and approximation
and i think in in each of these two
papers sort of the csc part that i think
is
coolest as a computer scientist is where
we can say like
look we show the complicated the the
optimal thing is actually reasonably
complicated but like hey here's this
like
two approximation or whatever um using
sort of classic cse tools
and we don't have to go you know it's
it's csc stuff but simple enough csc
stuff that you could you know
you don't need to be a computer
scientist to appreciate sort of what's
going on
there's economic insight as well so i
love
i love doing things like that
nice way to answer both at once
i mean it's essentially an answer for
everyone i guess so it's also an answer
for me
i mean it's uh i mean it
sort of generates nice interesting cs
problems i mean this this paper you have
this graph structure and there's sort of
like transferring satisfaction problems
are rising in this
this thing and it's never been studied
before i mean
similar things have been studied but
this kind is sort of
unique to this this persuasion scenario
and
i mean it's just uh it's nice that these
these things pop
up from from like economic scenarios
that
people have proposed in completely
different directions but then when
thinking about it algorithmically
there's like these interesting new
problems popping up
that's what's fascinating
hey gregory it's you
yeah yeah i also think that this is the
interesting thing
that there are a lot of interesting
problems that are
difficult to analyze and they seem to
have applications and
these are things that people from like
different backgrounds care about
particularly economists
so it's nice to have something that was
challenging
and has some real real world
applications that can motivate it
awesome any other questions
any other arguments that you want to
start
jason just kidding great great session
an awesome session yeah
i really i really love all of your
papers guys i
i think they're all really phenomenal
enjoyed your long talks as well
i really did watch them all and they're
you guys make beautiful slides
um and it was lovely to see you all so
thanks
hope to see you on gather thank you tara
thank you great job